[Music]
well of course you know that I was
involved only because I was the
president of the senior class that that
year and we were all surprised all of us
in the class were surprised when we
heard about the convocation and the fact
that we would have Winston Churchill
visiting us it was sort of a last-minute
thing with Lyndon Winston Churchill
because Harry Truman the then president
of United States was supposed to be the
featured speaker and there was a problem
about his being available and obviously
everybody was delighted that Winston
Churchill was there was the one selected
so we were looking forward to it and of
course at the same time we had the we
had the convocation I'm sorry that's not
the right word we had the inauguration
for a new president dr. Killian James
Ryan Killian and both of those events
occurred on succeeding days so it was a
really big weekend at MIT now the the
Winston Churchill event was first and
there were a number of us who were
chosen to be student guides I'll call
him four or five of us who were active
in in student government and that sort
of thing it a mighty that year and I can
recall that the the director of that
event was the head of the naval
architecture department and wil Cochran
and we were fundamentally assigned to be
to be hosts if you will for the for the
ladies for mrs. Churchill mrs. Winston
Churchill mrs. Randolph Churchill some
of the other ladies of the party and we
would guide them up and down the stairs
if you will and bring them out to their
car and that sort of thing it really
wasn't much more than that quite frankly
but it gave us an opportunity to be a
part of the of the of the operation
there were other things as well
obviously the the night of the of the
event in Boston Garden was a momentous
occasion Boston Garden is no more today
but it was it was the the main arena in
in Boston indeed in New England at that
time the capacity was 13,000 and it was
filled to capacity that night that
Winston Churchill spoke I I was I'm
reminded that I was one of the eight
people that was sitting up on the up on
the stage behind Winston actually seven
if you don't in cloud and include
Winston Churchill but it was it was very
interesting to be sitting behind him
obviously everybody else all of us had
had our eyes focused on Winston
Churchill and I was over his left
shoulder so to speak
watching him deliver the speech which
was a very very impressive thing it was
an impressive speech of course but he's
an impressive man and it was just
interesting to watch him when the little
movements that he would make and it is
his handling of the speech itself the
other one of the key points was
certainly the the the walking in if you
will it's a an occasion like this
obviously with seven or eight people up
on the stage they all walk in at the
same time and so the sequence of people
sitting at the stage even though I was
furthest away from Winston Churchill in
order to walk on the stage I'm the first
one to walk in so they indicated that
this is how its to go and that it would
be in this sequence and I was the first
one to walk in and walk up the steps and
walk across the stage and sit down at
one of the eight seats that were there
and so actually I took a deep breath and
started walking and the rest of the
people followed the rest of that the
other seven followed me and obviously
when they saw the people on the
staged walking in there was a tremendous
applause and obviously the applause was
for Winston Churchill and not for any
other or any of the other of us but it
was it was sort of interesting to hear
that that roar as you walked across the
stage and I just
of course walked over very modestly and
stood at my chair until the other seven
people arrived and stood at their chair
and then we sat down and they began the
festivities the other thing that I can
recall about it is that obviously I was
listening to the speech as best I could
trying to keep my mind on on his speech
and also the the magnitude of the event
but we're sort of interesting to see how
he handled his his speech just from a
administrative standpoint if you will
he had yellow pieces of paper with his
notes on it it was hard to tell that he
was reading quite frankly but he was
reading and he would as he finished it
was not a pad it was not a loose-leaf
binder it was simply sheets of paper and
as he finished one sheet of paper he
would just let it fall to the floor and
so it you know towards the end of the
speech there was sort of a pile of
yellow paper at the left side of the
rostrum which was a little interesting I
don't know whatever happened to that
paper obviously I was considering
picking up some on my way out but just
wouldn't have been the thing to do the
atmosphere at the Boston Garden was
exciting people were people were talking
I mean before it all happened before the
speech started everybody was was excited
and waiting for him wondering wondering
where where he was at such etcetera
people were there early I'm sure tickets
were very scarce she couldn't get in
there unless you were invited you were
an alumni I don't think very many
students were able to get in but
it was it was electrifying if you will
and of course his speech was very well
received standing ovations as that as
you can imagine when it was all over we
we went back to our routine of of
guiding the the the ladies on our arm up
the hotel stairs and that sort of thing
it was one of the one of the things that
sort of delayed the the next event there
was another event afterwards a reception
for at the Statler a post a post speech
reception I guess you'd call it at the
Statler for MIT alumni and I guess they
expected about 2,000 people there and so
that was the next stop for Winston
Churchill and we went to the Statler and
once again will the ladies on her arms
bringing him up the up the stairs to the
lobby that was before they had
escalators in a lot of the hotels in
downtown Boston and we found that or
what Winston Churchill found that he was
at the wrong hotel he had expected to be
at the Ritz which was where he was
staying and so he had left some things
back at the Ritz so he asked if we could
go back he asked the man that was in
charge of marshalling everybody around
I'm not sure it was the FBI or whatever
but yes that we he could go back to the
Ritz before we went any further because
he had some things he wanted to pick up
back there so we marched everybody down
ladies on our arms again and got they
got in the cars and went back to the
Ritz picked up there what picked up
whatever he wanted at the at the Ritz
somebody said it was a hairbrush or
something but I'm not sure that was
exactly true and we returned to the
Statler again where he relaxed a few
minutes and then came down to the
ballroom and made his address
unfortunately he was a little late for
the reception but people didn't mind
they were having a having a good time
well mrs. Churchill was was delightful
she wasn't she isn't was an American and
appreciated America very much I'm sure
and she was just a very friendly lovely
woman you just you just you know your
did she just she didn't she didn't
strike you as being the wife of the
Prime Minister quite frankly but she was
a very lovely woman I did also have the
opportunity to meet her daughter-in-law
randolph mrs. Randolph Churchill was
there with ran with Randolph Churchill
Winston son and one of the times I I was
escorting her up the stairs or down the
stairs I've forgotten I've forgotten
which you'd be interested to know that
she she was the ambassador to France
later on in life
I've forgotten exactly what the
circumstances were but she did marry
Averell Harriman and he died sometime
after that but she was a was a hostess
in Washington for some time and then was
appointed ambassador to France and it
was Pam Harriman was was her was her
name but at the time I met her she was
25 year old wife of Winston Churchill's
son and interesting interesting young
lady or she was you know five or six
older five or six years older than I was
so she was she was interesting let's put
it that way well it was a it was a
little it was a little on spiring and
yeah obviously you're a little nervous
on something like that that was
particularly nervous for the speech that
I had to give at the inauguration and
that was the that was the next day as I
recall that was in Rockwell's cage and I
was I was to give the address
representing the student body welcoming
or congratulating
dr. Killian and welcoming him to MIT as
a representative the student body and so
I you know rehearse that quite a bit but
it went off it went off well I I was
happy with it so that was that was the
that was the biggest chore that I had
the the being the escort on the night of
Winston Churchill's speech wasn't a
problem because it was a sort of a fun
thing to do obviously and there wasn't a
lot of pressure and me preparing for a
speech or anything of that anything of
that nature well I was very fortunate as
a very fortunate to be in that position
obviously and I look back on it and it
was a tremendous experience that you
know you wouldn't do without I was there
was some little things about Western
Churchill there was sort of interesting
as I as I look back on these things he
liked oysters and it would seem that
whatever wherever we were he'd be he
would have called for oysters because
there'd be a cart coming up the elevator
and rolling down the hall to his suite
where he was and excuse me and he would
have ordered oysters and and whatever
else he takes for the oysters I don't
know I know he smoked cigars because we
had cigar smoke all over yeah but he
certainly loved oysters in Boston
there's a good place to be if he like
oysters well I guess the convocation was
planned first that was I'm sorry I guess
the inauguration was was planned with
the convocation but at that time we had
no idea Winston Churchill would be
coming it was simply a inauguration of
the new president of MIT and then it
come a mid-century convocation and the
principal speaker was Harold was to be
Harold Stassen of course and he came and
did a wonderful job but then they they
were trying to keep the the major
speaker they did
disclose him until further down the
further down the timeframe and it was -
it was to be Harry Truman and he was not
able to make it we didn't we didn't know
that at the time we found out later that
the the original speaker or prime
speaker if you will was to be President
Truman and and he was not able to come
for whatever reason and and so Winston
sure it was announced that Winston
Churchill was coming and I think that
announcement must have been within days
of the of the event I can't recall maybe
a week or so can't recall precisely but
we knew about the inauguration and I
knew personally that I was I had been
asked to be the representative of the
student body at the inauguration and
that I would would which was asked to
give a short speech of welcoming so I
prepared for that and that was that was
probably a couple of months ahead of
time so it was plenty of time to you
know prepare and make sure I remembered
everything well yeah I suppose I felt
you know I I suppose it that's the case
but see I got like how to respond to
that one I was very fortunate to have
been selected to do that and I'm sure
that I can't say that either I don't
know if they were jealous or not let's
put it that way I don't I don't think so
I think they realized it was a something
that had to be done although I don't
think you want to use this part of it
here but there weren't that many
students around let's put it that way
there weren't that many students around
at the time because it was spring break
and so and indeed one has some mixed
emotions do you want to take advantage
of spring break or do you want to
participate in this obviously I I wanted
to participate in this there was really
a a lifetime opportunity so I was I was
I was delighted to do that but many of
my friends were we're off somewhere else
or relaxing or that sort of thing the
the inauguration as you know was held in
Rockville
age Rockledge had just opened at that
time indeed there was some concern that
the cajon might not be ready for the
inauguration but of course it was the
inauguration of the new president and so
I'm sure they worked overtime and got it
ready but it was literally the first
event that was held there there were I
don't believe they even had the the
normal sports activities there until
this event was over and that was of
course packed with with both students
and and faculty and alumni there was
astute as we walk what was we all walked
in we had caps and gowns on as I recall
and as we all walked in there was a
student section for for seniors and a
special place for them to to walk to
march in with the parade and of course
with inauguration many university
presidents are invited to the
inauguration and so there was a lot of
men with doctor's hoods that part of the
parade was very was very colorful as you
as you saw all the presidents of
universities from all over the world
marching with they're very colorful
hoods and each one as you know is
distinctive for the university that they
represent and so that was very
impressive and then up on the stage and
once again I had a favorite seat but and
I was called upon to as I say to make my
speech which I did and got through it
satisfactorily so I was happy with that
oh yes this was the this is our
president our former president Carl
Compton had been there for 25 years and
he had done a magnificent job of all
during the war he was the it was the
president of MIT and the radiation lab
without with the big contribution that
it made to the war was all very well
appreciated and and at that time people
were just realizing how important radar
was
and sonar and the basic research was
done right if that radiation lab and at
the Lincoln labs under the under the
direction of MIT and indeed the staff at
MIT van Busche who was the vice-chairman
I think at the time made a very
significant contribution to the war
effort with his work at the radiation
lab so it was an exciting time and
indeed it was it was an honor for dr.
Compton as well because we were honoring
him as the retiring president and of
course the inauguration of the new
president and that was a ton that was a
that was very well attended I think by
the students know I could I don't recall
the speech and I don't know whether I
thought you know there was a book that
Dean Burchard who was the chairman of
the convocation wrote a book it was sort
of a collection of all of the all of the
speeches at the mid-century convocation
as well as a collection of the speeches
of the of the of the speech of Winston
Churchill that night and I I've looked
through the copy of the book when I
didn't see my my speech in there so I'm
sure it's around somewhere act so
actually the book was was mainly for the
speeches for the convocation the book
was about the mid-century convocation
not about the inauguration so it will
really we really shouldn't have been in
the book anyway well I'm of course we
knew him because he was the vice
president at the time and then when we
graduated like this was in April of
course and so our graduation was in June
and obviously by that time he was
president so we had many of us had an
opportunity to to know him and meet with
him as a and during during the during
graduation week the president has a
reception at his home and so we had an
opportunity to meet him there and and as
his wife and family and he's and then of
course I remained as president
for quite some time so during alumni
affairs I would always renew my
acquaintance with him and he remembered
me as the as a student who gave a speech
in his inauguration day and I and indeed
his wife remembered too I think because
she was she was a very alert individual
who who who knew the students and and
remembered them well I think at the end
of the day of course it's the end of
which day you know I mean there were
really two big days there the day of
Winston Churchill's speech and on the
day of the inauguration and I believe
the day of the of the Winston Churchill
speech preceded the inauguration so I
really wasn't going to do a lot of
celebrating the first night because I
had to get a good night's sleep so I'd
be in shape for my speech on the on the
second night so but then when it was
over I've obviously I felt quite relaxed
and and it was all behind me but you
know it's a lot of pressure on a 21 year
old I would say but it was fun and I
enjoyed it and I look back on it with a
with a deep sense of pride well I was
you know I expected it to be in the
newspapers but it was really surprised
to see that it was front page headlines
in the Herald and the post and so I was
very interested and certainly interested
in that and read his read his speech I
did you know I couldn't remember very
much sitting there on the stage behind
him you had your mind on a hundred
things but it gave me a chance to get
some you know to understand what he was
saying and a little better so that was
that was interesting in all of the
pictures think they had some really
great pictures and indeed this one is a
picture of of mrs. Churchill and I
walking down the stairs and that's a
delightful picture that I have hanging
on my wall at home you know you don't
get pictures like that every day of
course you have to yeah I guess I should
answer that question by by indicating
that Winston Churchill was such a
remarkable man that it's just a pleasure
to reflect back on that whole experience
the man had tremendous foresight
obviously a world leader he he
appreciated the United States very very
much obviously he was one of the best
friends the United States and have had
and of course I like to think the United
States one of his best friends I'm sure
he would say that too in fact the the
the main headline in the Boston Post I
guess at the time was Winston says the
Russians would be in the UK if it were
not for the US and indeed I I think he's
right he was he was a man who had vision
I mean obviously as a as a young man I
didn't appreciate this but as we see all
that's happened in the last 50 years
Winston Churchill had vision well this
was I of course
people my age just sort of missed World
War two some of us had to go in at the
very end I was we we entered MIT and
while the war was still on I entered MIT
in June of 45 and that was obviously
three months before the war was over and
we all expected to be you know to be to
be called in at the time we entered MIT
and they had the ROTC we were all
privates in the ROTC that first year or
two that we were there and but then as
it worked out I didn't have to go in
until the start of the Korean War so my
vision of World War 2 was not the same
as somebody in our class for instance
who had been a veteran who had been to
MIT earlier and then went in the war and
then returned and we have many of our
classmates in the class of 49 who who
are of that age so my vision was was was
not the same as theirs where they
participated in the event but as I look
back on it I realized what what a
tremendous challenge Winston Churchill
had during World War two
beginning with the the onslaught of the
Germans and the and the beat and the v2
rockets and the
and the possibility of invasion of their
islands and and then I realized the
great moves that were made by the United
States with lend-lease and Liberty ships
and indeed the eventual joining of the
UK the eventual joining of the Armed
Forces and indeed the United States
didn't make the difference and and did
bring peace back to the world so that
gave me a chance to you know as I look
back on the 50 years I realized some of
the things some of the some of the
things that Winston Churchill was saying
at the time some of the things that he
was warning us to look out for in the
future and so that that I reread his
speech every once in a while you know I
was very fortunate to be elected senior
senior class president and in June 1949
and and I had been somewhat involved in
student government but I never dreamed
that I'd be involved with Winston
Churchill or dr. Compton or dr. Killian
to the extent that I was and that was
that was a real surprise obviously it
was a delightful one and I enjoyed it
very much
the Winston Churchill opportunity was
was a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
to observe that that that man had a de
Burgh to observe that man very closely
well as a as a student I came to MIT in
June of 1945
you know fresh out of a public high
school and rye New York and was
wondering what was all going to be like
and I worked hard my first year I think
but my grades were just average and it's
somewhat of a shock to come from a
school and you know your your grades are
considered pretty high and then you get
to MIT and you're just run-of-the-mill
average see but there were a number of
us and we handled it as best we could
and went on and and learned it was a it
was an excellent education
you know obviously not just the courses
themselves but the discipline that was
necessary to you know to handle four
years at MIT I changed courses like many
people did I started out in mechanical
engineering and then went into
Industrial Management but many of the
courses were more similar I began to get
into more of the business courses and
was interested in marketing and began to
be interested in marketing and my
sophomore my junior year I guess but it
was a great experience I look back I
come to MIT from time to time for alumni
events and although I don't live around
Boston I could get to Boston
you know regularly and so have a chance
to keep track of what's going on at MIT
and I like what I see well I was living
in the dorm for a while I've had the
dorm experience and I'd then I was in a
fraternity as a matter of fact for for
most of my four years and that was a
that was a nicer perk experience it was
there was advantages and disadvantages
to being in to living in a fraternity
were further away obviously but allowed
you to get allowed you to get to know
people a little little easier a little
more easily and it was it was fun gave
you something to do when you had some
free time and I met a lot of really nice
people
but I think that the whole MIT
experience is the is the is the
important phase of of the education it
gave us gave all of us a great start to
to a life and of course this is my 50th
year and back for my 50th reunion with
many of my classmates and as we look
back on our 50 years it's it's been it's
been very rewarding and we've got a lot
to thank MIT for I do have an
opportunity from time to time to walk
down the halls and and and see what's
going on at MIT when I'm here for a
meeting
some kind and MIT hasn't changed that
much we still have the same notices on
the bulletin boards though there are
some new buildings obviously the new
library wasn't there when I when I was
here and many of the athletic facilities
are are improved I think probably
probably the dress code is is less than
it was when we were there but that's the
way it is all over I mean young people
our young people are changing and they
changed at MIT as well as they change
every any other place but they just look
like regular students as far as I'm
concerned I did have a chance to
interact with with some of them I was
fortunate enough to be invited to a
dinner at dr. vest house a month or two
ago and there they had they bring
seniors in there in a rotating basis to
to sit down and and have dinner with him
and chat with him and they bring some of
the alumni that are in town or in the
area to join them and so I had the
pleasure of sitting with 8 or 10 of the
seniors and chatted with them and they
you know they they seemed like regular
people I talked to I talked to two of
the two of the boys played lacrosse and
I was I played lacrosse at MIT as well
so we had a lot of things in common to
talk about and the of course I there
were more ladies now at MIT than they
were there were when when I was there I
think we had four in our class at the
time at four in our freshman class as a
matter of fact there was there more that
then that finally graduated because a
number transferred in fortunately but
that's that's a change that we see in
all universities and a happy change a
happy change to be sure so that's
certainly one certainly one difference
but I found that I found the students
not basically different from the
students that that that were a part of
my own class
well they didn't but they may have had
other experiences I'm sure that we're
we're almost as grand no I don't think
they were no my parents weren't there my
course we had my family I'm one of five
children and so there's there were five
of us within six or seven years so the
other four children were at home and my
father at the time I believe was working
in Washington for the OPA this was the
war was well and the war was over though
excuse me
let's back off on that and this will
give you an opportunity to cut a little
bit here no my parents weren't able to
come up for the inauguration they did
make my graduation I'm happy to say but
I didn't I didn't really and they had
lots of things to do and there's four
kids at home that take care of all
younger than I so I didn't really think
it was necessary to urge them to come
and I'd really had no knowledge I think
when we talked about it as to how I was
going to be put I didn't really know I
was going to be participating with
Winston Churchill I mean I I just knew
at that particular time then I was going
to be talking about the inauguration and
the the Winston Churchill operation sort
of followed followed along and I think
those numbers I think about six or eight
seniors that were involved and and being
ushered if you will for the for the
ladies and I think that we just really
got into that about the week before I
think so it really wasn't the thing to
you know I didn't it didn't really make
it didn't make sense to extend
invitations at that particular time you
know I didn't I don't believe it made
the hometown newspaper I doesn't see the
hometown of course our hometown just has
a weekly paper but I didn't I didn't see
the hometown newspaper but when I
graduated it did make the hometown
newspaper
no they didn't mention about Winston
Churchill or anything I don't think that
I don't think they picked that up in the
hometown newspapers oh yes indeed some
of them are some of them will be coming
to the reunion and so I we're looking
forward to talking about that but
generally speaking it's something that's
happened in the past and I well I'm
pleased with with the opportunity to
participate it's not a subject I bring
up myself
well I think it was I look back on the
opportunity that I had it was a
magnificent opportunity and one that one
that I could not have foreseen when I
entered MIT or indeed when I began my my
senior year to have shared the platform
with Winston Churchill as a 21 year old
was a was a was a dream that is that
simply one does not get normally and I
look back on it and I was a very
fortunate person at the time to be sure
I tried to be modest about it when I
bring the subject up but I'm certainly
very proud that I was a participant at
that event